are there any double standards in
relationships that do not favor women
but do not favor women i think so i
think sometimes guys are able to like
dog around a bit and get away with it a
bit more you think so i think so like
not maybe not so much in ireland but
like i get the impression like france
and italy and stuff they're kind of like
yeah go for it it's all cool
do you think that women dog around
though you don't think women do the same
thing i don't know like i think when
women talk around they're more like like
committed in their minds to i think it's
more like yeah i'm like gonna go for
this guy whereas guys can just do it
like yeah [ __ ] whatever have you
heard of the prado principle in dating
um what is that something like 80 20 no
i haven't if you ask 80 of women what
they want in a man they list 20 percent
of men so the reason that women hate men
is because we're all sleeping with the
same ones disaster
and the majority of men are actually
like not having sex yeah i
mean clayton
um okay what are what are women's issues
um some women's issues
i don't know like
uh pay
pay stuff
like like pay ceilings and that kind of
crack um can you name any men's issues
um
i don't think men have issues really
like it's just so easy and good really
the majority of suicides are men the
majority of homeless are men
workplace deaths family court systems oh
[ __ ] uh
no it's just like interesting because we
always hear about women's issues but we
never hear about men's i was why do you
think that is
um i don't know like i i think it's true
though i think that like women's issues
like and this may be sound sexist but i
think that women's issues do come to the
fore a lot more i think demands it but
men are bad as well because we kind of
like hide our issues and bury them a bit
i think yeah but it almost is like like
women can come forward with their issues
in society but men can't like they're
almost shamed for it would you agree
yeah to to an extent but then like i
think at the same time like men do
probably have it easier all around so
there's a bit of a balance in it somehow
you think so i
i don't think that men do really yeah
like how could you say that men have it
easier if the majority of suicides are
met
like we're like
i don't i don't know i feel like there's
a lot of kind of like boys will be boys
associated with being a man where it's
just like oh like let him off that kind
of thing whereas i don't think women
have that like i think if women do
something that like society disapproves
of it's just like disapproved up it's
funny because like we're the
like i think the opposite like like
women i feel like we can do whatever and
like even you know jada and will smith
yeah like jada's like what if will smith
cheated with someone 20 years younger
than him
that would be looked at a completely
different way than if jade is doing it
like i think we get away with a lot
yeah but i don't think will smith's
getting away with hitting someone on
stage like two days ago oh my gosh she
is though they gave him an applause
yeah okay
he's not getting any charges pressed but
it's almost because it was in the name
of his woman
yeah like
i don't know it's funny like so i don't
know how long this thing got but i like
i went to um a
really diverse university with like
people from all like different parts of
the world and like i really think that
like there's less of a divide between
men and women
as there is between like just people of
different like socio-economic
backgrounds i think that would be like a
more distinctive divide than the divide
between men and women
well it's almost like men and women are
more i would say i would say women today
like have more power than we've ever had
and freedom
yeah like and and like
fair enough i i think
it should be somewhere how related to
effort that people put into their lives
like in different areas that they should
get the reward whether they're men and
women but then
everyone has natural like a certain
limitation to their lateral capacity as
well so if you can be unlucky and just
born in a like without
much
mental strength for example do you think
there's a such thing as female privilege
yeah yeah i do like i think say for
example if like when you're talking
about a woman cheating before like i
think if like if a woman cheats like
it's usually like
the men who have it out like even if
it's totally her fault so stuff like
that i think can really take her
you know i don't know if this is as
common in ireland so this is a more of a
us question but why do you think men are
taught how to treat a woman but women
aren't taught how to treat a man like if
i say like a man should pay for the
dates open doors that sort of thing it's
it's commonly accepted but if if i say
to a woman you should cook clean that's
like looked down upon almost would you
is that similar in ireland and
why do you think that is if so
um
like i no i think that that might be
just like a kind of like zeitgeist thing
like i think that it's a bit time and
place related i'd say like for example i
don't get the impression that in eastern
european countries like uh that
there is that same uh focus on like
teaching men how to treat women i think
that they have like women are also told
oh this is how you kind of like deal
with the man kind of thing so i think
it's i i and i think that those kind of
things come full cert like i think that
that will come back to a balance
somewhere in the middle eventually yeah
i agree
i agree thank you